[Music]
hey
everybody wednesday we're back
and we're talking about another
halloween movie because it's halloween
week
yeah god damn it and we're like gearing
up for the [ __ ] holiday
this is a really good one really uh yeah
this is
well like i said i'm really into horror
anthologies all around
um you know and obviously some are hit
or miss or whatever
the weird thing about this is that this
is tales of halloween by the way which
came out in 2015.
i saw this movie like a year or two ago
and i remembered liking it but when we
watched it again last night
i was like man i forgot how [ __ ] good
this was
yeah i liked it every story and it was
good yeah yeah
it's like some of the ones are better
than others obviously because there's 10
stories
but i mean all of them are worth
watching yeah practical effects
uh it's got a lot of directors from
other famous horror movies are in it
yeah cameos yeah a lot of [ __ ] shout
outs and homages to other movies you'll
you'll you'll see them
you know uh you know shout outs to
carpenter
uh [ __ ] like they in the little boys
room they're panning across his toys one
of them is the car from the the movie
the car
i liked that one because i was like ooh
deep cut yeah
also i also i love that that kid in the
first segment
was uh he was dressed as snake pliskin
though yep
i'm pretty sure because he was yeah he
had the shirt with the zippers on the
top
it wasn't zippers he just put white
stripes on him yeah that's right and he
had a [ __ ] pattern he had an eye
patch and he had like little uh
stubble yeah that he drew on his face
i was like oh that's so cute yeah every
story on it's good they're all
short they don't you know what i mean or
they're short or as long as they have to
be in order to get the [ __ ] point
across none of them are extended
you know so and none of them are like
curtailed they're all
the flow is correct and it's just crazy
[ __ ] man looking
trick-or-treating and a little kid
[ __ ] this forced to pull a trick on
this guy's
house and it turns out the guy that
lives there is the devil
the devil [ __ ] played by barry
bostwick yeah for christ's sake
so the devil i'm not gonna spoil it all
but the devil takes him or
takes him all around town they [ __ ]
committing all kinds of crimes and doing
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
running with the devil it's like that i
was going when are they gonna come up
with van halen running with the devil
because he was running with the devil he
was yeah then there's a twist at the end
um little kids [ __ ] attacking people
adults like
night of the living dead like a zombie
type thing but they're trick-or-treater
kids
then there's a twist at the end just a
lot of good [ __ ] man every story was
good
it wasn't a bad story in it i don't
think there was and it's weird because
this was essentially 11 different
directors
um and given that this is a remarkably
consistent anthology lots of eye candy
lots of eye candy yeah good looking
girls [ __ ] in every [ __ ]
story lots of leg shots sexy [ __ ]
cleavage
yeah [ __ ] sexy costumes sexy costumes
shots with the [ __ ]
die high [ __ ] stockings and just
good thighs and legs and [ __ ] they know
what they're doing they even got
adrian barbos in it yeah she plays like
a radio dj like the narrator just like a
frog
now her boobs aren't in it but
she's in it her voice you know yeah and
she because that
that's another homage that they made to
it like over the thing but yeah there's
like tons of there's uh
one of the one of the ones i think it's
the devil one
um has adrian curry who's playing
herself and i was like who the [ __ ] is
that and then i like i looked her up and
they're like oh she's kind of famous she
was like on america's top model or
something so she's like on tv
i didn't know who she was because
everybody was like acting like she was
famous and i'm like
who is that but i guess she is famous i
just didn't know but they but she like
turns up in it and she's dressed up like
um she's dressed up like uh sarah from
legend like when she's darkness's bride
that really cool outfit with like the
big [ __ ]
collar and everything and i was like
what look at that
but yeah like all the all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and um
so yeah there's like tons of cameos in
this there's tons of like
homages in this to other movies but not
in a real
i guess it's not like a real winky winky
type of way they're like hey look at all
these famous people that are in the
movie they're just kind of like in there
like in the background and they don't
really like make an issue of it
which i liked but like i said this is 11
different directors 10 different
segments because one of the um
segments had two directors like two guys
that worked together all the time
but they shot it they shot all the
segments like
one after the other like on the same
street like they had a suburban street
that they were using as a set and a lot
of the stories
and i didn't realize this until i was
like looking some [ __ ] up and like the
second time i saw it
um a lot of the stories like interlock
like sometimes like in
the later like stories it'll refer back
to something that happened in one of the
other stories
except like kind of in the background
you know what i mean so like some of the
characters so they actually did kind of
go out of their way to make this like a
cohesive
um movie like all these things were
happening at the same time kind of like
trick or treat did i guess
because that kind of thing better than
trick or treat though um i would but i
think this is just as good as trick or
treat
i would just i would put it right up
there with that it's like this seems
like a really good thing to watch it's a
bit
i see trick or treat again i got it on
dvd yeah we reviewed that one too
like that that's definitely i mean if
you're talking about halloween anthology
movies
i'm thinking that you know this one i
think
i don't think this one's better than
creep show sorry really yeah
there's more pretty tall there's more
stories i think the stories are more
exciting
there's a lot more um gore in them
and a lot more action in them and i
think the storytelling
i think sterotown was was superior and
[ __ ] that's saying a lot with
creepshow creep shows the [ __ ] like
this
that's kind of like the biggest i think
it's better
i don't know if i'd go that far but i
mean i definitely like this one as much
as trick or treat and i like
trick-or-treat like i really like i
think it's better than trick-or-treat
yeah that's just my opinion yeah
you know i i think the stories the
stories drew me in they were faster more
fast-paced
this is a fun movie it's really fun yeah
i mean
they're doing [ __ ] like there's one
story called
friday the 31st which was a mash-up
between evil dead and friday the 13th
this second hot girl [ __ ] dressed up
a lot on what she dressed up like
dorothy
dorothy yeah with a [ __ ] sexy ass
dorothy costume
bad [ __ ] happens to her you know what i
mean [ __ ] freddie comes after her she
gets killed
it's jason jason well jason adjacent
yeah like a jason type of spin-off and
then
i'm not gonna spoil it but she ends up
coming back to life
kind of like out of the evil dead and
uh she's in this sexy costume with this
[ __ ] demonic face
trying to fight jason and uh
it's it's over the [ __ ] top i mean
her titties are flying out
she's already dead with chainsaws and
chopping arms up yeah sexy tall [ __ ]
stockings on and [ __ ] it's just the
movie is
is aimed towards pleasing the crowd it's
not trying to make any kind of political
statement or anything it's just trying
to over the top itself
well like i said [ __ ] story was it's
just fun building on the other one yeah
yeah [ __ ] two neighbors
one of them's an old school guy he's got
his old school
[ __ ] halloween setup that he's been
putting in his yard for 20 years
some new people move across the street
and they're all black metal [ __ ]
hardcore [ __ ] black metal punk
rockers and [ __ ]
with this over-the-top new halloween
setup they start getting into a
halloween
super super battle
decoration yeah halloween decoration
battle you know
[Laughter]
yeah and it's satanic as [ __ ] across the
street
mauled up bodies and it's just over the
top and he's complaining he says this i
this is not right you know it's just you
just gotta see it yeah so dj maniac asks
is this the one with dana gold yeah he
actually is
he's the he's the man with the with the
nice halloween display like in the one
we were just talking yeah that's a good
one
yeah he like lives across the street
from all these like new like heavy metal
people that like
to move across the street it's like yeah
they're out there like dancing and [ __ ]
yeah it's like dancing and then misfits
and um fun fact the guy that played the
head like black metal guy
that was the same guy that played frank
the rabbit and donnie darko okay and
he's also in a bunch of like greg iraqis
movies too
like doom generation and stuff just as
the whole thing unfolds you start seeing
all these directors from horror movies
in it
and if she didn't point them out i
wouldn't realize who it was i was seeing
it's not like they're doing a stephen
king
corny cameo or oh there's stephen king's
[ __ ] buck to that
not acting [ __ ] [ __ ] two days
his asses
[Laughter]
stephen king will [ __ ] his own movies up
real quick
and start [ __ ] the movie like oh they
got brought stephen king back
well they got there's actually one uh
story in here
i think it's called grim grinning ghost
and it's this one's basically just
this one's not like super over the top
or gory or anything it's just basically
just like an old school ghost story
and they have that like a little
halloween party at the beginning alex
esso is in this who was in starry eyes
she was in
um she was in uh haunting of bly manor
she was in
uh dr sleep and um so she's in it
lynn shea plays her mom you know from
all the conjuring movies and everyone
else at the party
it's uh stewart gordon uh mick garris
barbara crampton who i did not actually
recognize at first i just
recognized her voice and lisa marie who
was in a bunch of tim burton movies so
that was all at that party
but like i said that was like a very
brief scene uh john landis is in one
playing uh the the millionaire father of
a kid that gets
kidnapped sort of um but that's not how
it goes and also
the one um the last segment
which i don't know if i could pick a
favorite but the last one is pretty good
about the [ __ ] killer pumpkin yeah
they had and that had a really good like
homage to halloween three which i really
appreciated that actually had uh
joe dante in it also yeah business i
can't check messenger right now
it'll close my window i'll check it
later fourth throw down said honey this
atm just called me an [ __ ] yeah that
was from uh that was from
maximum overdrive but yeah so like i
said it's hard for me to pick a favorite
there were some that i liked more than
others i liked
um the last one which is called the bad
seed about the killer pumpkin
um sweet tooth which is the first one
about the
the urban legend about the um demon that
like if you don't give him some candy
like he'll come in
that's a pretty good one take the candy
that's like really it was really good
like really gory and like the monster
and it was like really cool looking
this kid was pissed off his parents took
his [ __ ] candy and ate all his
[ __ ] halloween candy yeah and what
was funny is they really played it up
the kids like you took on my [ __ ]
halloween candy creeps up on him later
on
trying to look for his candy he sees his
mom and dad mom was [ __ ] she was
she was [ __ ] hot mom and dad are
[ __ ]
on the [ __ ] was the bed of the couch
goes the couch they're on the couch
in a pile of his candy just getting it
on
[ __ ] eating the candy to feed each
other
just rubbing it in that they got all the
[ __ ] candy
and the kids sitting there staring at
them like those [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my candy right just yeah it
is you can't blame them
pissed off man get pissed off that was
that's exactly like something some kid
would might imagine what they might be
doing with this candy
i bet you they're [ __ ] in that cage
and eating it and eating it at the same
time and they're like
rubbing it on each other it's just a
great scene man
yeah that's what your parents are doing
with the [ __ ] candy
you wake up and they're like i don't
know where your candy is you can't eat
at all
you get fat yeah then they have to like
quick go buy it some more yeah
that's [ __ ] funny but yeah so well
and i also like in this that um
that it's really kind of like nasty like
it goes for like a lot of little kids
get killed in this
yeah and also a lot of kill kids like
kill adults
um you know at one during that the
second one about the devil
which is called the night billy raise
hell um just basically they have
somebody going through the town just
like [ __ ]
you know he puts like a flaming like
bear trap in somebody's yard it like
cuts their foot off they're just like
shooting people randomly like in the
street
and [ __ ] like that so it's like it
really kind of goes all out with like
the nastiness but it's so like
over the top it's funny that it's funny
yeah you know what i mean so it's not
like
you know i thought that was funny the
kid would imagine that that's exactly
what a kid would imagine his parents
were doing with the [ __ ] candy they
took the candy i bet you they're [ __ ]
all that candy
that's what i mean that's a well that's
what made that so funny for me
his jealousy was [ __ ] going through
the roof
[Laughter]
um yeah uh these nests
want to know the cheapest way to send
t-shirts send into
two t-shirts dude that's gonna be 15
bucks at least when you say jenny
yeah weight-wise you just got to go to
it well wait did it like or we said in
it where we send it
it's it's continental u.s oh okay that's
usually only to do two
t-shirts it usually only costs like
seven eight bucks like something like
that because i think it's four or five
like for one but like as it gets heavier
yep usps man you just got to go to usps
and they got a little machine
you put it in the special package and
then
send it out 78 bucks dj maniac says
yo i didn't realize until a few years
ago that when my parents were checking
my candy for poison they were [ __ ]
stealing me
but that's what's so cool about it
because like i said it's like if you
were a kid because i remember like being
a kid and you like worked really hard
for that candy goddammit like you put on
this and especially in florida when it's
like [ __ ] roasting
at halloween and you went around in your
costume like schlubbing the bag around
and got all this candy and then you got
home and like
then you're then your parents would
collect a candy tax that's what they
always said that's what they called it
they'd take their campaign my parents
didn't do that but i knew like somebody
because my my
parents were just like whatever just to
eat it all we don't care
and we were like thank you we will but
um yeah we were talking about that the
other day how
because you don't have any siblings and
i do and i do but it's like so
you didn't know you didn't do like the
whole big candy trading summit like when
you got home from trick-or-treating
where everybody would pile all their
candy in the middle and they'd be like
okay my brother likes this and you don't
like that and you can have now we can
divide these up and [ __ ] like that
i just got what i got and eat everybody
[Laughter]
there wasn't anything i didn't like yeah
you were like a candy vacuum
yeah i eat it all well you had to like
what i liked to do
is that if nobody would take like my
kind of mediocre candy off my hands
i would actually kind of like eat that
first and i would save the good [ __ ] for
later but i'd have to hide it like i
said because sometimes
you know parents or siblings or
something would get a bit peckish and
they'd come in there and like
raid my stash but i like to like save
the good [ __ ] till last
i would eat like the kind of mediocre
[ __ ] like first
i remember they mostly handed out those
where i lived in
california they were mostly giving out
those damn sweet sweetie what are they
called sweetums
sweeties what was that what you laughing
what'd they call that [ __ ]
i think it was sweeties or sweeties they
were like
sweeties i think god i hated those they
gave out a lot of those
well they're cheap yeah it came in that
big bag that had those and it had those
like little lollipops
yeah like those kind of [ __ ] we ate them
anyway
the lollipops i liked the pineapple ones
and then got a lot of those butterscotch
oh no i like the i like butterscotch
yeah the gold wrapper i'd eat all of
those not really go
but yellow clear like red yeah yeah i'd
eat those and
like any kind of starlight mints or
something like i don't like the cinnamon
ones but i like the butterscotches
but you know what i mean i liked those
little like [ __ ] crunchy
what the [ __ ] were those they were like
little bars and they were like kind of
crunchy peanut but it was like a
butterfinger but it was like kind of
like rectangular california we got a lot
of mexican candies too
a lot of different kinds of like uh it's
like a piece of paper
that [ __ ] had little little button
drops on them
uh mexican yeah and lollipops yeah
mexican lollipop is like a it's like a
cone with three different colors with
the mexican flag color
yeah it looked like a folded up umbrella
but it was just
it was a lollipop i showed that i showed
that to jair
who's you know he lives in if you guys
don't know who it is he's a
he's a fan of the show
but uh he uh lived in tijuana and i was
telling him about those little mexican
umbrellas
and he kind of forgot about him and i
showed him a picture he said oh yeah
they stopped making i forgot about those
yeah that's not something that they eat
anymore today but they yeah
they gave those out little mexican
candies
i've heard of a couple of those but i'm
not real familiar with it
yeah yeah um but yeah i was gonna say
okay so
out of like all these ten stories i will
say there's a couple of them
that were good but i didn't love them
the two that i didn't love were um
the one about like what was it called
the week in the wicked or something like
that it was kind of like the bullies
and it was almost it was set up like a
western kind of and it was just like you
know the three
like the girl and the two guys that were
like going to beat up that one guy oh
yeah yeah yeah i didn't see it as a
western it was kind of more like a
post-apocalyptic
it was but it the way it was shot they
were homaging i guess
a western i guess and like the music was
kind of like western he was like yeah
demon king had the demon of like all
hallows i liked the demon though the
demon looks uh pretty cool
and um now the one with uh
with pollyanna mcintosh who many people
might know nowadays
as the leader of the trash people on
walking dead
um she was in one that was called what
the hell was the name of that one it was
like a hansel and gretel riff
um and that one was a little i think
lucky mckee directed that who was
probably most famous for directing
may and uh he also did the woman which
was pretty decent
but um that one was just a little
the makeup that she did like her in it
was great like she was
because she was a witch but she would
like [ __ ] demon out like when she got
mad
um and that was super cool but i thought
like it was a little
disjointed and weird but and it wasn't
as quite as funny as the other ones
but other than that i mean like i still
liked them but those were just the only
two that i didn't really love
but i still like i said i think sweet
tooth which was the first one like about
the
the candy stealing demon and the last
one
about the killer pumpkins which i think
is called bad seed
um i think those two were my favorite
ones because the best thing about bad
seed the
the pumpkin eating with the one the
pumpkin that like eight people
um was that they did it like
they shot at like a police procedural
and they played it straight but they had
like everybody that was in it like the
cops and everything they talked like in
cop
movie cliches but they played it
completely straight which i thought was
hilarious
and um one of the funniest moments of
the whole movie for me
is when you know this guy gets his head
bit off by a pumpkin right
by a jack-o'-lantern and um then like
his wife is like trying this like
talking to the police sketch artist
it's like the detective comes in the
police sketch artist like turns the
thing and he's
like this crayon drawing of a pumpkin
with teeth and [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] funny and then they do
like the
they did like the bite marks on the head
and like they bring in like the 3d
thing that they made it looks like a big
pumpkin mouth and [ __ ] like that it's
just funny it's funny as hell
karen um she corrected me it wasn't
sweeties they were called smarties
smarties smarties that's right and you
know what's confusing about that is that
they have a candy called smarties in
canada
but they're more like m m's they're like
chocolate and they call smarties
yeah and then kanavasan also is in there
under his look in pseudonym right now
he's in there in his easio
ezio auditory whatever whatever the hell
that is
so he has you an author he has to hide
he's hiding
he's in troll mode you see
see that's jair yeah all right
well you're blowing his cover i'm
blowing his coat
sometimes goes by a con of atslam well i
don't understand that you know because
khan
the con that he's talking about is the
court is of course
is of course [ __ ] khan noony and
singh also
played by ricardo montevillon ricardo
monteblon
was the [ __ ] alpha alpha males of all
alpha males of mexico
see so he's the ricardo monteblon
of otzla that's what he's talking about
okay
what is ocelon that's all the land
they're going to take back from us
down there in the southwest that's
auslan see
mexico is going to take all that back
tell them khan
then uh see dude what's going on
that's pretty funny yeah oh no
nobody's gonna be nobody's gonna beat
ricardo monte blonde that was all man
right there that wasn't prosthetic
that wasn't [ __ ] that wasn't
corinthians yeah
you know what i mean they had people
saying oh man there had to be a
prosthetic
chest and arms he he's not that big
because they look that was big back in
the day
well yeah back in those days he said no
that was all man [ __ ] ricardo's like
man look at mr works [ __ ]
chest man yeah and he'd [ __ ] come off
like he was some kind of a [ __ ]
castilian
lord from [ __ ] spain and [ __ ] that
dude i think i think that i think they
do from tijuana i think it was from
tijuana
uh yeah maybe i can't remember where
exactly because i remember like looked
him up along
the way for something yeah he played it
off like he was some kind of a [ __ ]
part of the the la conquista
yeah yeah i gotcha yeah like he was one
of cortez's men
[Laughter]
sorry i was just looking at my notes
about friday the 31st and all i could
think of was that little i'm not going
to say what it is because um if you
haven't seen the movie there's a
slasher parody and then like a really
funny like random
thing happens yeah but i was just
remembering the little
twinkle tweet now he just like keeps
doing that was just like making me laugh
all over again
we had a [ __ ] blast watching this
movie last night it really like
like i said it really kind of like i'm
glad that i saved this one for wednesday
and i saved this one for today because
it's kind of i was i was trying to like
make it so it was like getting more and
more halloweeny like as the week went on
you know what i mean
yeah so yeah jayer says he has all these
accounts because that's how he
hides from the mexican deep state okay
[Laughter]
fair enough all right so
uh are are you done talking about you're
done yeah is it old man nap time
yeah yeah a little bit
i gotta check the mail oh yeah that's
right it is about that
and then i want to see that uh i want to
see that uh
uh what's his name i don't know joe
rogan's show from last night
joe rogan they had [ __ ] alex jones on
there yeah
he got everything he got loaded he's on
there drinking
yeah it's a three-hour show man that's
going to be awesome he's breaking the
[ __ ] internet
breaking the internet well make sure you
turn the volume down because i'm
breaking it
like you hear all that [ __ ]
i don't need to hear all that yelling
from all the way across the house i can
hear the tv he's just telling the truth
he's just telling the truth uh okay yeah
if you say so
yeah it's a show it's a show
it's a show it's it's certainly that
yeah i'll give it that much
yeah truth is just a lot of times just
depends on a certain point of view
yeah okay yeah oh i was gonna say too
that the last the
going back to the movie for a second the
last segment of the of the
movie bad seed the with the pumpkin that
was actually directed by neil marshall
the same guy that did the
the descent and uh dogs holders okay so
there you go
so yeah like i said and you will
recognize pretty much everybody that's
in this [ __ ] movie there's like
but like i said they don't do it in an
obnoxious way you know because even a
lot of the actors i recognize from other
[ __ ] and like
jayer said his wife is deep state his
wife is the deep state yeah his wife is
the dc
yeah she's watching you she must be
watching him
i don't get that i don't she's just
watching i don't i don't watch what
you're doing yeah i know but she's just
watching
he's in mexico though because i got
better get in trouble you can get
trouble real quick in
[Laughter]
and mexico doesn't cost much money to
get in trouble mexico
well you can get in trouble anywhere if
you got a little imagination
all right so we're wrapping this up so
uh like i said this is a really really
good horror anthology
very very halloweeny just fun gory um
nasty over the top hilarious lots of
like evil dead homages lots of that kind
of [ __ ] so if you're really into horror
movies and you want to see it
if you haven't seen it um you should
definitely watch it right around
halloween time
it's on shutter and it is also streaming
on 2b if you don't have shutter even
though
you should um but so you can watch it
either place
um and i guess that'll do it for our
live stream today
and next live stream is going to be
saturday night's big
online halloween party okay
got all our costumes ready yeah we gotta
go get some halloween candy tomorrow
though
we got boo i'll probably be right be man
in the door i'm do as i'm doing the show
too well that's okay like if it like if
the doorbell rings if we get a lot of
trick-or-treaters i don't know if we
will
because we didn't really get that many
last year now that i'm thinking about it
um
i think we maybe only got a dozen people
but i don't know if we have any little
little kids living in this neighborhood
anymore yeah we do got a [ __ ] ton of
them oh really maybe some like moved in
since
that [ __ ] yeah so i don't know so we'll
see how it goes so if like
so if he has to keep getting up and like
running and doing the doorbell it's like
i'll just handle
the [ __ ] yeah i guess like usual yeah
i'll be drunk [ __ ] answering the door
handing out candy
dressed just like the dude from the chat
stuff like michael caine from the head
all the little kids would be like who
the [ __ ] are you supposed to be
they're not gonna understand all right
so we'll see you guys on halloween night
thanks for dropping by bye